PROPERTY DAMAGE AND THOUSANDS OF
COPS INJURED WITH BRICKS AND
ROCKS AND MOLOTOV COCKTAILS.
HERE'S ALINA HABBA ALONG WITH
ANALYST JARRETT WITH A WONDERFUL
ON FoxNews.com EXPOSING AG
GARLAND'S BEHAVIOR.
ALAINA, I GAVE A LIST ON A
MONOLOGUE TONIGHT.
IF YOU'RE CONSERVATIVE YOU'RE
TREATED ONE WAY.
IF YOU'RE DONALD TRUMP OR A
TRUMP SUPPORTER YOU'RE TREATED A
VERY DIFFERENT WAY.
HERE'S A VICE-PRESIDENT
LECTURING US, AND SHE, HERSELF,
IS TELLING RIOTERS THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO STOP NOR SHOULD THEY
STOP.
SHE'S THE ONE PROMOTING A BAIL
FUND FOR THE PEOPLE INVOLVED.
SO ARE WE SUPPOSED TO REALLY
LISTEN TO HER?
WHERE'S THAT INVESTIGATION?
>> SEAN, IF YOU USE YOUR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT, WE'RE GOING TO
COME AFTER YOU AND CALL YOU A
DOMESTIC TERRORIST.
I WANT YOU TO BE PREPARED.
SO YOU AND I ARE GOING TO SHARE
A JAIL CELL.
THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT SHE SAID.
YOU KNOW, DON'T DISAGREE WITH US
OR WE'RE GOING TO COME AFTER
YOU.
THIS IS NOT AMERICAN.
WHEN ARE WE DONE WITH THIS?
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO GET ON THE
SAME PAGE, CUT THE GARBAGE AND
REALIZE WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO OUR
COUNTRY.
SORE LOSERS CANNOT PUNISH THE
RIGHT SIDE OF THE AMERICA,
BECAUSE WE SEE THE COUNTRY FOR
WHAT IT IS.
WE ARE FAILING, INFLATION IS
HIGH.
TRUMP IS LEADING IN THE POLLS.
IF HE QUIT TOMORROW THIS WOULD
ALL BE DONE SEAN, THIS WOULD BE
DONE.
I SAY ALL THE TIME YOU WANT TO
BE DONE YOU WANT TO FIRE ME GET
RID OF ME SAY YOU'RE NOT
RUNNING.
YOU WON'T NEED LAWYERS ANYMORE.
THIS IS THE MOST SICK VERSION OF
OUR COUNTRY I HAVE EVER SEEN,
HONESTLY.
>> Sean: GREG WE HAVE FOLLOWED
THIS CLOSELY THE WHOLE RUSSIA
COLLUSION HOAX, NARRATIVE ALL
THE RAIDS ON CONSERVATIVES AND
NONE OF THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE
FOR LYING TO FISA COURTS, NONE
OF THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE LIKE
HILLARY CLINTON, CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, E-MAILS, BY THE WAY,
33,000 DELETED, THAT WOULD BE
CALLED OBSTRUCTION WHERE I GREW
UP, NEVER ANY ACCOUNTABILITY,
THERE'S NO RAIDS, THEY HAD
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP FOR TWO
YEARS.
WE KNOW THERE'S EVIDENCE OF
CRIMES ON THE LAPTOP.
WE KNOW IT IMPLICATES HIS
FATHER, THE BIG GUY, AND NOBODY
SEEMS TO CARE ABOUT THAT GREG
JARRETT.
WHY.
>> BECAUSE THERE'S NO EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW THAT'S
ENGRAVED ON THE PEDESTRIANMENT
OF THE UNITED STATES SCORE.
MERRICK GARLAND HAS SEEN TO THAT
AND SO HAS CHRISTOPHER WRAY AND
THE FBI.
EXCUSE ME IF I JUST DON'T TRUST
THE FBI THAT PERFORMED THE
WOORNT TRUMP'S HOME.
THE FBI HAS A LONG AND
DISGRACEFUL RECORD OF LIES AND
CONCEALMENT AND MANIPULATION.
YOU'LL RECALL THAT AN FBI LAWYER
LITERALLY DOCTORED EVIDENCE IN
ORDER TO GAIN A WARRANT TO SPY
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE FISA COURT EXCORIATED THE
FBI WHEN THEY DISCOVERED IT AND
BAN I SHOULD ALL FBI OFFICIALS
FROM EVER APPEARING BEFORE THEM,
THOSE THAT WERE INVOLVED.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL AT THE DOJ
THEN CONDUCTED AN SCOFFED I HAVE
INVESTIGATION GOING THROUGH
HUNDREDS AND FOUND SAY SHAMEFUL
PATTERN OF LIES, MANIPULATION,
CONCEALMENT, BY THE FBI IN ORDER
TO SECURE WARRANTS TO SPY AND TO
SEIZE DOCUMENTS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS PARTICULAR
WARRANT THAT WAS SERVED AT
TRUMP'S HOME.
IT IS A GENERAL SEARCH WARRANT.
WHICH IS MOST OFTEN HELD TO BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
WARRANTS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
NARROWLY CONFINED, SPECIFIC
PLACES TO SEARCH, AND SPECIFIC
ITEMS TO BE SEIZED.
THIS WAS A FREE FOR ALL.
GO ON IN THERE, GRAB WHATEVER
YOU WANT, TURN THE PLACE UPSIDE
DOWN, RAN SACK IT.
AND I THINK THAT WAS THE WHOLE
PURPOSE OF MERRICK GARLAND AND
THE FBI, TO GO IN THERE AND TRY
TO FIND SOMETHING, ANYTHING, TO
IMPLICATE DONALD TRUMP IN
CONCEIVABLE CRIME, SOME IMAGINED
CON SUSPICIOUS CONSPIRACY
RELATED TO THE RIOTERS ON
JANUARY 6TH.
THAT'S THE TRUTH OF WHAT'S GOING
ON HERE I THINK.
>> Sean: AND THAT WOULD BE THE
PRETEXT OF ALL THIS.
ALINA, AS THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTORNEY, DO YOU WANT THE
AFFIDAVIT OF MERRICK GARLAND TO
BE MADE PUBLIC?
I KNOW THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID HE
WANTS EVERYTHING MADE PUBLIC.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT IS THERE.
YOU KNOW, DON'T FORGET, WE HAVE
THE HILLARY SUIT WE ARE STILL
PURSUING, WE HAVE MOTIONS TO
DISMISS PENDED.
I WANT TO KNOW WHY ROSENSTEIN,
WHY SCHIFF, WHILE ALL THESE
ACTORS ARE HELD TO A DIFFERENT
STANDARD THAN REPUBLICANS.
I AM SICK AND TIRED OF SEEING
THE CONSTITUTION BE USED
DIFFERENTLY DEPENDING ON YOUR
POLITICS IT'S ANTI AMERICAN.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT'S IN THE
AFFIDAVIT, WHAT THE BASIS WAS
WHEN YOU HAVE A COOPERATING
PRESIDENT WHO HAD NO PROBLEM
LETTING YOU INTO HIS HOME TWICE
BEFORE.
WHAT IS YOUR JUSTIFICATION FOR A
RAID TWO MONTHS LATER AND THREE
MONTHS AFTER YOU GET THE WARRANT
WITH A JUDGE WHO RECUSED HIMSELF
FROM MY HILLARY